[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
welcome walter hi martin
uh it looks like you're doing well
well
our topic is such that we have to be in
a cheerful mood yes
it's a very important subject that we're
talking about and it has to be an
encouraging subject
that would sometimes look as if we're
negative that's not the aim no we want
to uplift the church so let's pray
our heavenly father thank you very much
for another discussion that we can have
we ask again that you please enlighten
our minds bless the discussion
and have your angels around us in this
important
matter in jesus name amen amen
so we're continuing with nothing against
the truth but
for the truth right
and the aim of
this
whole
effort
is to show that no matter how negative
things might appear
god is still in control
and the other aim is to show even if you
think
that everything
is wrong in a particular area of the
work there's always something that's
also right in a particular area of the
work
and when we look at it from our human
perspective
we can despair
but if you look back
over time then you start understanding
what god is doing you can do nothing
against the truth
you can only do something for the truth
so even if
powers that be introduce very very
negative things
then the lord permits that to
create awareness and debate on the issue
and enable each individual within that
sphere of influence
to make a personal decision for or
against
and it's it's like a great sieve
that is being applied
now martin let me just say one more
thing
if you want to apply a great serve
and you want to introduce things that
will cause
or let's say you want to permit certain
issues to be introduced that will cause
a debate
and people to think
it's no good introducing it by someone
who has no influence
so the obvious target to bring in
negative things
will always be in the upper echelons of
leadership yes
but that doesn't make all of leadership
negative or obsolete
very important that's a very very
important point because we are so prone
to categorizing
and demonizing a whole
institution because of the decisions of
a number of people yes like you said in
the previous one
this level is okay this level is
there's something wrong no no in
everyone there's this is god's church
from the top to the bottom
and
yes there will be a shaking
and yes the bible even says that the
lord will cut off the head and the tail
that doesn't mean that everybody in the
head is going to be cut off
but that many of the ideas that have
been inculcated even in the head will be
cut off
the same happened in the time of jesus
as we spoke before
not everybody was cut off in fact
hundreds of priests
and leaders came out
and accepted the truth and stood for
truth and righteousness even in the face
of opposition right correct it'll be the
same at the end
so i'm hoping
that the stories which i have to tell in
my personal life
because as we said last time these are
not things you normally talk about
and there's a six part testimony of my
life yeah
on the internet
but i'm sure we could make a six or a
more part
one on what happened behind the scenes
as well
and
i just want to say that this is not
being done to be vindictive but as
encouragement that's the thing because a
lot of people will
have a personal
experience of this
and when it becomes personal then it it
it rattles you correct so
this is to give people that have
personal experience hope
yes
and if you take any of uh
the biblical figures
those that stood for
for
the truth that stood for the word that
stood for the testimony
they always had the wind
from the front always and as martin
luther already said wherever there's a
true christianity it's upstream it's
never going to be downstream no we had
the promise from jesus himself and look
how they treated jeremiah look how they
treated isaiah look how they treated any
of those
there are very few
that were embraced and accepted
and most of them
had a very hard time exactly so why
should it be different
so let's start again by
reading from the testimonies
never did this message apply with
greater force than it applies today
more and more the world is setting at
not the claims of god
men have become bold in transgression
the wickedness of the inhabitants of the
world has almost filled up the measure
of their iniquity
this earth
has almost reached the place where god
will permit the destroyer to work his
will upon it
the substitution of the laws of men for
the laws of god
the exaltation by many human authority
of sunday in place of the bible sabbath
is the last act in the drama
when this substitution becomes universal
god will reveal himself
he will arise in his majesty to shake
terribly the earth he will come out of
his place to punish the inhabitants of
the world for their iniquity and the
earth shall disclose her blood and shall
no more cover her slain
you know in the past they always say yes
but where's this thing that you're
always talking about that will happen
right yes yes
when is this ever going to happen it is
the last act in the drama the last one
why because it is the ultimate attack on
the authority of god
because the sabbath commandment
is the only commandment
that asserts the authority of the law
giver exactly because he's the creator
and he is your redeemer
and he is the one who has the authority
to put his stamp in in the light of his
title the creator of the universe onto
that law
it's the law of authority exactly none
of the others contain
that authoritative statement that
legal aspect to make the law binding
yeah
so it'll be the last one that he will
attack that doesn't mean there will not
be other acts in the drama correct it
actually just tells you they will be
other acts and
also
that authority
on the law
especially the sabbath yes when you
choose between the two
either you go for it or not your
allegiance
to whom you are creating authority is
perfectly shown the other thing that's
very important we also stated in
previous discussions that we had
that
when you look at that prophecy of daniel
or where the abomination of desolation
will put its footprint
even
in that portion where it should not be
even within the very church right
so we can expect that we can expect that
that doesn't make the whole church
apostate but we will find elements of
that
now in the last discussion that we had
in our first one in this series we
looked particularly at the evolution
creation
situation and we mentioned the health
aspect to a certain degree that that was
also highly problematic right yes
and
that portion will become more and more
prominent
as we see events unfold in the future
so
what what did we not speak about we
didn't speak about these other aspects
about who makes
this law of god void
and who are his associates
now surely if he knows there's an enemy
that is going to expose him on this
issue he will make every effort to
counteract that at the level of the
church yes right it's a logical strategy
it has to go from inside
best way correct this is a war and in
every war you will employ that strategy
you will even drop leaflets
over in enemy territory
to indoctrinate the man on the street
the foot soldier
as to you know the way he should think
etc so and you will use the radio waves
and the media and everything that you
can do to influence
mind upon mind
now when we looked at the issue of
creation evolution
what was the the sticking point when it
came to the church
evolution versus creation there were
many in the church that were
evolutionists
they shouldn't be there
they should find another church
where
they can believe what they like yeah
aya was an evolutionist and it said in
six days the lord created that was very
hard to get my mind around that
but that's the basis of the sabbath
and if you accept the sabbath then you
accept the six day creation otherwise
you reject the bible so if you don't
want that then don't call yourself an
adventist
then go and find yourself a place where
you can
believe what you want to believe
right
but the sticky issue
was
the time frame
the short time frame versus a longer
time frame
and even from the highest echelons of
leadership
it was blatantly said that when the
spirit of prophecy
refers to 6 000 years
then the author of the spirit of
prophecy was influenced by the margin of
the king james version yes
now
that is an incredible statement to make
furthermore
those same
individuals in those echelons of power
said yes we agree
that she had the same inspiration as any
of the other prophets but not the same
authority
now that's an oxymoron yeah
if god speaks through someone
and he gives the same inspiration then
that inspiration must have exactly the
same authority as any other right
it must have because otherwise it is
totally useless correct now we've
discussed that before when we discussed
the veracity of the spirit of prophecy
so those are issues that make your
antenna go up
so
in my life
my falter is the bible and the spirit of
prophecy that is what i believe
i don't have to believe anything else
if there is something in addition
a creed for example
then that creed can only be accepted if
it's in harmony with the bible and the
spirit of prophecy the same with anybody
else
whatever they tell you no matter how
high they are in the organization
if it doesn't harmonize with the bible
and the spirit of prophecy
then for me personally i reject it
absolutely and i can give you a few
examples
my story in europe is not a very rosy
one i've had some very bumpy roads to
travel
and
the evolution creation debate was just
one of them
but that was still a minor ripple
when it came to the health issue
it became
a major ripple but when it came to the
spiritual aspects then it became a
nuclear war
that's the way it is right
now very early on in my career
as a evangelist
i
not only spoke about science
that was still
acceptable
to a degree
not with everyone
but when i started venturing to speak
about the religious aspects
then the opposition
became
uh
very vociferous let me put it that way
and
this is a very interesting story
now why did i feel compelled to go into
that that kind of discussion
because of my background yeah i came out
of a world of atheism
but i was involved in occultism
and
through the associations that i had i
had a reasonable
knowledge of the operation of secret
societies
and i'd actually been
in the temples where these channels
were communicating
messages from the other world to high
officials in sport and government and
medicine it's always interesting it's
always those three
sport government medicine and then
behind the scenes the churches were
involved
and when i was with that one channel
the channel for africa
when i was in his home
then it became blatantly clear that his
connection with the theological schools
was a very strong one
which is which is amazing because
what has luciferianism got to do with
theological schools right
now many of those that grow up in this
church and end up in positions of
leadership have never dabbled in
anything of of that nature
they cannot even comprehend it to them
it is a fairy tale right
but this is in actual fact the fact of
the matter
and then we have
those hundreds of statements on secret
societies in the spirit of prophecy yes
and then they want to tell me that the
secret societies has nothing to do with
our message
where she blatantly says that if you
study the secret societies then you will
understand what john is speaking about
in the book of revelation
so how do you get those two together
right
and so i started off with with lectures
because i came out of babylon
on the wine of babylon
because i had to get my mind around it
what was wrong
with the babylonian doctrine
what was wrong with the doctrine of
catholicism and we we did a number of
what's up the doctrine of the serpent
right
i mean it's very wrong it's blatantly
wrong and so when i started lecturing on
the wine of babylon
and i brought in all those images to
show that what they were teaching
at the theological level
in many many institutes in the world was
babylonian wine
and so one of my first lectures on this
topic was the wine of babylon
and then i started talking about secret
societies
now that
freaked people out
they hadn't
seen it from that angle and so many were
upset
and then of course when you're talking
about babylon you have to identify
babylon yes
you have to say who the beast is
what's the point of saying come out of
babylon
and you don't tell the person what
babylon is all right
it's meaningless
so come out of babylon so you have to
define babylon you have to say who the
beast is and you have to say why is
babylon and what his wine is
and then you have to identify the dragon
which is spiritism
which is the belief
in what satan
told eve
in the garden of eden
and that according to the scripture is a
lie yes so you have to expose that right
now if you are dabbling in economical
relationships
then this becomes very very embarrassing
right let's be quite plain about this
let's say this blatantly
our church officially is not supposed to
be affiliated with economical relations
yes
it's very clear in the spirit of
prophecy
and anything to the contrary is
something that happens because people
feel that that might be an avenue of
creating better ties however it happens
it doesn't matter
but in the past god always said you must
be a separate people that's it and if
you like you said earlier are exposing
and telling the people to get out of
there
you can't go in there yourself then you
have a problem correct and then the big
driving force
that fire
that is in your soul
that you cannot
that you cannot quench
is to go and warn the people
because why should they die
if they could understand
that they could accept the truth and
they could come out of those systems and
embrace the truth
what an amazing turnaround that would be
right
if i may ask a question here how many
people that have accepted the message
and came out of there
came to you and said why did you get me
out of there no they all said thank you
every single one of them
and uh if the person who brought me into
the faith hadn't told me who the beast
was of which i was part
because i was raised a roman catholic
then
how would i have known to come out of it
right
so
very early on when i started off with
those first lectures the wine of babylon
and revelation chapter 13.
i got a phone call
from
one of
the leadership in europe
in fact from the highest echelon of
leadership in europe from the division
and it had been advertised what i was
going to speak on and there was a
pamphlet that had been printed as to
what my lectures were going to be
somewhere on science
on evolution
but there were also other lectures that
dealt with these issues such as the wine
of babylon for example
so i get this phone call from this
official
and he tells me in the middle of the
night
late at night
he
phones me and tells me
that
i may speak only on science
i may not give those lectures
but they've been advertised right
so the pamphlets had been out the
posters were out they'd been advertised
and i was supposed to do a campaign
right
so he tells me i'm not allowed to do
that
so i said to him why
why can't i do that what's wrong with it
and he said to me
you are going to
call the pope antichrist
and
we we don't want you to do that
and i said why don't you believe it
and he said it's antiquated theology
i said that's very strange
because in the spirit of prophecy it's
very clear that this is
the problem
and you're supposed to
expose the man of sin in your exposed
yeah it tells you quite plainly you have
to expose the wickedness of the man of
sin who has made the sunday lord
distinctive mark of his
of his character right
and so i said to him
um
excuse me but
do you believe the spirit of prophecy
and he said to me
that is 19th century outdated thinking
i was
stunned now i didn't expect that right
yeah because i'm in this church i think
everybody's on this page this were when
you were still
new very new this is very early on this
is one of my first appearances in europe
and
i was taken aback and i thought wow this
comes from
this comes from the highest echelon
now i'm not saying that everybody in
that echelon was on the same page as
this particular individual
but nevertheless that's what he said to
me
and so i thought about it while he was
talking and then i said to him
i'm sorry i cannot do what you are
saying
so he said why not so i said because
you're not a seventh-day adventist
whoa
i can imagine
he exploded
on the other end
so i said no you're not because when i
came into this church
i accepted the points that were on the
baptismal certificate
and i
accepted those as part and parcel of the
teachings of this denomination and you
are telling me
that i should go contrary to that
conviction so therefore you are not in
my opinion a seventh-day adventist i
will not listen to you
that was it i gave my lectures
now obviously
that was
in the time when i was young and feisty
now you're just feisty
no now just young
and
it must have been like
throwing down the gauntlet to some of
these people
so this created quite an atmosphere of
animosity in those that were of like
mind as this particular individual in
leadership
now
the president of that division at that
time
he was an extremely
liberal
man when it comes to
what we believe
and for example in his time
the things that came into the church
were spiritual formation
willow creek theology
celebration style worship
they would take whole churches and
change them
into celebration type churches they
would
basically get rid of those old
conservative people that were
bible-based spirit of prophecy based
that didn't want to go in that direction
and they would engage the youth and
bring this in and to me this was
blatant apostasy at the highest level
in fact
this particular individual
was
extremely antagonistic
to
what i was preaching for example
and i had a phone call or two with him
and even meetings were arranged which
never materialized even though i had an
appointment
he didn't pitch
and uh so i realized that you know even
if he is the president of a division
if he doesn't speak in harmony with the
bible and the spirit of prophecy
i will ignore him
when it comes to these things and your
reaction wasn't
arrogant
i i hope not i tried to be respectful
but if they speak
totally against what the spirit of
prophecy is saying
then i have to put it through that
filter
and i
also feel
that
i had a particular calling
yes that's to give a particular message
within the framework of the bible and
the spirit of prophecy
and why should i listen to someone who
goes exactly contrary
to that kind of situation right yes if
you bring back the stories of the bible
was elijah arrogant when he was speaking
to the king no he was not arrogant he
was just for right forthright he said
i'm not the trouble of israel when they
accused them yeah you are the trouble of
israel because you're not sticking to to
what you know is right right
and so
i mean i was not the only one there were
many that were extremely upset by all
the liberal things that were coming in
and spiritual formation comes directly
from the jesuits it is a jesuitical
teaching and there are two lectures of
mine
about the jesuits and the
counter-reformation
where i addressed that issue
and that caused major major problems
because
some of these individuals would bring
that into our colleges
now that very division man that found me
and told me that the pope is not the
antichrist
and that is antiquated
doctrine
he became a professor at one of our
leading colleges in
germany
so if that's the kind of liberal
theology that is being taught to pastors
then
you have a problem with that and so
obviously uh the two ideologies are
going to be in conflict
now here's the the question again or the
kicker
why does god permit it
why
to get it to stand up to get a debate on
it to
open up the debate so that people can
make a decision
so when they start these churches these
let your hair down churches
they literally basically call them like
that yeah the the one church had written
on it la small locker
in english you would say let your hair
down you know do what thou wilt let's
have some fun
and
people took exception to it and said you
know this is not right when they start
bringing in the drums and the things i
mean ellen white says quite plainly
the one of the very last things that
will happen is they will bring drums
into into the worship service
and you find this everywhere in the
world now i've had some amazing
experiences
but let me tell you how god works
can i just ask before you tell us the
story um
the names that even had names for these
projects one project emerging church so
it was a whole movement correct and it
was
it's um
still alive and kicking correct
now some of these people were very
prominent right
they were division presidents
and even at the very highest echelon at
general conference level
they were
bringing in all of these things can we
have coffee churches well let's talk
about it let's do that you know let's
let's let's change this into
uh rather than you know these
old-fashioned
solemn worship services let's
bring it on and there were many that
were opposed to that
but
they had
the power and so it started happening
within the church
but martin you must always remember
that this church officially at least has
a bottom-up structure
if somebody makes a decision up there
that decision is not binding
it is not a decision that has been made
by a
conference call to get world conference
call together
at a session
where decisions on the way forward will
be made and those decisions are
representative of the whole body of the
whole body so there are many that will
do their thing
and they think that they represent the
church now those individuals that think
like that even if they are in the
highest position of the church
do not represent what the bible and the
spirit of prophecy says on the issue and
therefore they do not represent me
either
and they can go and sit if they want to
and vote on issues such as creation
vote against it they don't represent me
and
not until the whole church has made a
decision to reject let's say the six day
creation
well i have to make a decision do i
still want to stand with the church
but because an individual even if it is
the highest individual makes a decision
like that that's his problem
right
so
treat them with respect treat them with
kindness if you can
but when it comes to what is right and
what is wrong you have to stand like
elijah yes you have to say like martin
luther here i stand i can do no other
you do your thing i'll do my thing
because the two are obviously not in
harmony
yes it's important to remember
that they become objects of evangelism
correct absolutely well said martin they
become objects of evangelism and you
hope that like that young man i spoke
about
the other time
that he will come to some introspection
on this issue
correct
now you yourself
when you came into this church you were
confronted with issues of spiritual
formation and you say well what's going
on here didn't you yes and it was also
high up
we were part of an outreach organization
in the church and that there was some
training material and
under the training material there were
books
written by professors in spiritual
formation from secular universities not
part of the adventist universities and i
questioned this with
leadership
and to this day
it hasn't been resolved yes well i can
also say i had a discussion with a
conference president in the north
american
continent
and he took me to task because i spoke
against spiritual formation
and so i sat in his office he and the
secretary and
they weren't exactly on the same page as
i was in fact they were on the other
page
and so
they
they were taking me to task on the issue
and one of the books that i had quoted
was from an ex-quaker
which was richard foster
and it was on spiritual formation and
how you bring this into the church
and
they took exception to that
and he blatantly said to me in my face
that
richard foster
was as inspired as ellen g white
and i looked at him
and i said
oh you're absolutely right
only problem is the one is inspired from
above and the other one from below
and that of course ended the discussion
it's not possible to have a compromise
on that issue not at all and to
misremember like you said earlier
the spiritual exercises that's part of
spiritual formation
as its roots with ignacios layola
absolutely and even if it's got a nice
sugar-coated christian
garb
it's still rooted there correct
and i i had i got an invitation to speak
at one of our colleges that had
introduced spiritual formation at the
highest level
and of course they were very upset
that i was actually invited to that
place
but
they they booked a hall
and the people that came i mean there
were hundreds of them
and
it was so obvious
that there was an absolute divide within
even that
university that college
and that there were those that were for
it and those that were against it and
the staff members some of them had been
intimidated
even
even ask to sign certain papers that
they accept the the way in which they
were going to go
and they were highly indignant
because you know when you accept this
truth
you do it on the basis of careful study
and conviction yes isn't that it it's a
walk would you come into this church of
your own free will or maybe it's a good
idea to become an adventist would you
it's the last church you'll choose yes
i think it's easier to go to the church
of satan
than to make the decision to come into
this denomination right
the world will accept you much easier
correct so once you've made that
decision
and you've based it on the facts and
you've studied the issue
when you come into contact with people
within the church most of them sadly
i must say
are people that were never part of the
outside world and never had to make that
decision they were fortunate enough to
be born into it
but surely there are also enemies within
the camp
that have brought in some ideas and
we've already said who's who in the zoo
we do not have to say
but basically if you have come into this
denomination
then you have done it on the basis of
careful study
and therefore
it is not so easy for them
to
twist your thinking because you've
already made a decision
you've had to make big decisions and
leave things that you used to think were
true
behind and made a lot of changes now
when you discovered that whoa
there are spiritual formation things
here
what did you do did you continue or what
did you do or did you leave that
organization or what did you do well
the first thing i did was i thought okay
maybe
somewhere this crept in
and unknowingly
so i try to bring it to the fall
but then
afterwards i realized okay this is not
going anywhere but the we stood we were
part of this organization and
we were
led by god
if he decided we must stay there and
stay a beacon or whatever we would do
that but he changed our direction and
that's a whole
other story that's a different story
eventually he was also like you the
whole
trend of what we are doing
is nothing can be done against the truth
but for the truth correct so out of this
god
eventually
changed our direction
but he wanted to test us
if we are fully devoted to him and to
the bible and the spirit of prophecy
okay and so he changed our root and
that's how we ended up with amazing
discoveries
so in other words the conflict that
arises
around a particular issue let's say
spiritual formation
and you study the issue and you show
that it is a jesuitical concept
if it is a jesuitical concept you can't
as you say sugarcoat it and present it
as truth
it has inherent toxins in it
and so this creates a divide
and there will be decision making
right through the ranks and everybody
has to decide for themselves
i'll go along with this or i will reject
it and this is part of the shaking
so if you now come
and you give a lecture
against spiritual formation
they will automatically say you are
dividing and splitting the church
if you give a lecture
on plant-based diet
they will say you are splitting the
church no it is the doctrine
that is creating the shaking
the individual
is
irrelevant he's the messenger it's just
a messenger
nobody has to follow
martin smith
nobody has to follow a walter fight
is this truth or is this not truth that
is being presented
that is where you base your decision
another issue
that then arose because
a lot of antagonism
regarding my stand on babylon and
babylonian doctrine of which spiritual
formation and willow creek
methodology
which is a very emotional
uh way of presenting
the gospel
and it is in a sense also spiritual
formation because it elaborates
and dramatizes
whatever the gospel story says and the
spirit of prophecy is very clear
that any form of drama
is contrary to what god wants us to do
because the truth must do the cutting
not the emotional
flavorings that surround it right
that's amazing martin that once you
become attuned to it
and you start recognizing it
then no matter where it comes from
put it aside yeah because it is
dangerous it will take your mind away
from the plain truths of the bible and
put you on an emotional train
that can
infiltrate your mind with any concept
because you'll go into an alpha rhythm
yeah maybe if the there are viewers or
listeners that are more interested to
find out exactly what this constitutes
the spiritual formation
those two lectures are the jesuits and
the counter reformation and i'll again
put those two links in
okay now another issue that arose then
was the issue of bible translations
now martin
what had happened was i had read
wilkinson's book authorized version
vindicated
and
i took the bibles
and i checked whether this was so
and i took my niv bible and i compared
it with the king james bible and i
compared it with the new king james
bible
and in the german versions i compared
the old luther bible to the martin
luther bible and the elbafelder bible
with the
bible
and
i then read all the literature
of the committee that said
to put together the
bible which is basically
like the king james version
and what the reasons were why they had
reverted back to the receive text
and
i had
such an excitement because i discovered
this issue right
now unbeknown to me of course
this behind the scenes was going to
create another great war
now this is often how it happens if you
are forewarned about something you might
stay off that territory
but me in my
in my naive enthusiasm
i worked out two lectures
on bible translations
and
the way it came about that i gave those
lectures and where i gave those lectures
shows to me that even if something very
negative comes out of it
in god's providence
something positive can come out of it
right
so i was invited by a group of people by
a church
to come and do
an evangelistic campaign
in
europe
and in germany i was invited to come and
do this campaign and unbeknown to me
this little town where i gave this
meeting
was right next to
this university
where that division man became a
professor that didn't believe in the
bible and the spirit of prophecy
and where that division president found
me and lambasted me about everything
that i was doing
whereas he was bringing in spiritual
formation and all of these things into
the church so we didn't sit at the same
table
and
now how did i get there
i mean this is a little town
somewhere in the east block of germany
right
just after the iron curtain
came down
and
i had to fly to berlin
and i was picked up by a gentleman
and it's an amazing story
because this man
was quite a new
convert
to seventh-day adventism
and
we were sitting in a car for a number of
hours traveling from the airport to
this place and of course we were talking
i didn't know the man at all
and we were talking about
how he came to
embrace
these truths
and he told me an amazing story
he was in the east german military
and one of his jobs was to see that
nobody escapes across that wall when the
wall was still there
and he was a
ardent
communist
and an atheist
and that was his job
and he would make sure that nobody ever
got out of germany right he was
on fire for the communist ideology
and in the course of his his career he
had
occasions when he went to the west
he had he was one of the few that could
leave the country and go to the west to
recruit for the cause right
for the communist cause
and he also dealt with
occult issues within the military
like ufo
things and very interesting career in
terms of the military
and then
when the iron and he also occasionally
came into contact with a particular
person
that he found very interesting and that
must have been an adventist
and when he discussed some of these
things with that person that person told
him no that's a cult you shouldn't go
there
but he didn't know what that meant but
he somewhere he filed in his head that
that person was an adventist and he was
interesting but he wasn't on that page
and then when the wall fell
his whole ideology collapsed
right
and from one day to the next he was no
longer in the employ
of the east germans he was now in the
employ of the west germans because the
west german government took over the
military right yeah
and when he got his first paycheck
there was a deduction on it that had
never been there before
and it was for church tax
and he looked at this and it totally
freaked him out
because in germany
they deduct church tax
and that tax goes to
the mainline churches depending on you
know which one is there that tax is like
a tithe it's like a tithe you could say
that correct so what is this so if you
didn't want to pay that then you had to
explain
why you didn't want to pay it so he
marched off to
the new military leaders and said excuse
me
what is this yeah
and i said it's a church tax and then he
says i don't want a church tax to deduct
it and then he said well then you have
to not be part of a church
so he asked well
what does this mean
they said to him you must resign from
your church then you don't pay taxes
and he says but i don't even know what
church i belong to
so they laughed these these west german
new leaders
and then he he said to them
what is the largest church here in this
area and they said the lutheran church
and he said right so i will officially
resign from the lutheran church so he
wrote a letter resigning from the
lutheran church so he didn't have to pay
that tax anymore
and that weekend he went home and he
told his his parents about what happened
his elderly parents and they said to him
you resigned from the wrong church you
were born a catholic
now typically german efficiency went
back to the leaders and said excuse me i
resigned from the wrong church here's my
new letter i'm resigning now from the
catholic church
they laughed like drains
so
there he was his ideology was shattered
and so he thought now what am i gonna do
and so he remembered that name seventh
day adventist now i'm telling his story
it's years ago and i don't even know if
i'm getting it absolutely right so if
i've got a fact wrong here or there but
this is the gist of the matter
i found it fascinating
so he looks up in the telephone
directory
whether there are any adventist
institutions there he didn't even know
it was a church
okay
so he arrives there and he finds one
and they let him enter
and he says well
he wants to
join this club
he's always a club
so what do you guys do no we come
together on the sabbath on a saturday
all right what time etc there he arrives
so he did that a couple of times
and then he said to them excuse me
what is this what kind of a club is this
when you come here
and you sit here every saturday and you
talk about all of these things what do
you do a club must do something you know
either you play ball or you have sports
or whatever you just come and sit here
this is meaningless what are you guys
doing
and uh in any case how do i become a
member of the club
they said no you must first have bible
studies and you must be baptized he said
he thought it was a ritual just okay
let's get on with it here
let's do this no it's not so easy we're
supposed to do this that and the other
but of course in east germany
you know the faith had been undermined
for 80 years so what was left of the
original faith was
it was vague to say the least
and then eventually
the pastor of whatever church that was
said to him you know if you really want
to do something
the government
gave back all the confiscated material
because during the occupation of the
russians
they confiscated all the churches and
all the church material
but typically german they had mocked
them and labeled them and stored them
neatly in warehouses somewhere and all
this stuff
was returned to the churches
so here they had boxes and boxes full of
stuff
and they had an incinerator and they
were cleaning up so they said you know
if you have time after work on a
wednesday come around and help us to
clean up so that's what he did
and they were incinerating old papers
that were you know 80 years old already
and so he found boxes and he went to the
pastor and he said i found these boxes
with all these books in them what do i
do with them
and he looked at them and he said no
these books are outdated
you can put them in the incinerator
and he said
what kind of books are these or these
adventist books and they said yes
they're adventurous books now why do you
want to incinerate them because they're
outdated they don't matter anymore
and he thought but the adventist books i
took them home
and it was spirit of prophecy books
as i started reading great controversy
and all of these books
and he realized that these people that
were in the church
no longer believed the spirit of
prophecy
they were not adventists and he came to
the conclusion
that he had now rediscovered adventism
and that he was the only adventist in
the country
he didn't know
and nobody else believed this
and now you know east germany was in a
big turmoil
and so eventually he he went from town
to town to town
and he tried to find people that still
believed
these writings
and
it's an amazing story right and
eventually they found a group together
of about 25 people or something in that
region
that still believed that
and so
they decided
let's all come together and create a
church where everybody still believes
that and that's the church that invited
me
isn't that amazing yeah so they believed
the spirit of prophecy and they thought
well let's evangelize and that's why
they said let's invite someone who
believes the same as we do
so they invited me right
i had nothing to do with it i didn't
know who they were i didn't know where
they were
i didn't know that it was right next to
that
university and so when it was
broadcast that i would come and give
lectures there
the rector of that university who by the
way
apparently
according to some sources said about the
spirit of prophecy that you cannot be
dictated to by a woman with only three
years of education
to which i
then quipped well if god speaks to you
through a donkey you better listen
let alone a woman with three years of
education
but in any case he wrote a letter to all
the students
forbidding them
to come to my lectures
okay
probably didn't go well that backfired
in a big big way
so he wrote this letter to all the
student body and said they weren't
allowed to attend
my lectures and of course you don't do
that to a student
no matter of what country
no matter where you don't do that to a
student
best advertisement they could have sent
out they were all there
but when i got to that first evening
they had they had arranged such a such a
a show
in this little town they had the mayor
there
with
the mayor's chain around them they had
an umpa ban
can't believe that
an umpa band and the umpa band was going
but it was a real old german thing
it was it was very interesting very nice
and uh the hall was full and all these
students
sitting there as well
and i started my lectures and i got onto
the stage
and as i got onto the stage
a man
came walking
to the front
where i was standing i was about to
start
after the introductions and the umpa
band and the mayor's speech and what
have you
and he came to me and he put his finger
in my nose
and he said to me are you going to
preach the three angels messages
i thought you know he was weird
maybe he's not quite compass mentos or
whatever
but i was quite taken aback and i said
well if he knows about the three angels
messages he must be
an adventist right
so i said
yes i'm going to preach the three angels
messages
and he turned round and he shouted to
that entire hall
this man is from the devil
he's going to preach the three angels
messages
get out
everybody here get out
this man is from the devil oh and i
started praying and i said lord
help what's going on here now
and the mayor was looking and the man
was looking
and it was a strange occurrence and i
prayed lord and he went through
the the aisles and he shouted at the
people get out get out
get out this is from the devil it's the
three angels messages
and i prayed and i prayed
and then he just walked out the door
and he carried on shouting down the
street or wherever he went i don't know
where he went i was on the inside
so i thought okay
now i have to calm the nerves of
everybody again and i'm sweating
and
so
calm everybody down i said that was very
strange occurrence i apologize for
whatever happened i don't know how that
happened it's not part of the script but
it's an interesting introduction so
let's continue so i greeted everyone
again and i just started talking
when a lady is somewhere
on the left hand side in the in one of
the chairs suddenly goes ah
falls off a chair
big consternation everybody's running
around is there a doctor in the room the
doctors go
and they're working with the lady and
i'm saying lord
there's so much activity here there's so
much opposition i prayed
quietly there for the lady and they took
her off into a side room
and she recovered she came back in and
as far as i know she sat and listened to
the rest she i don't know what she had
whatever
but that's how it started so immediately
you know
something's going down
and so you pray and you know that you
are on very dangerous ground
and i gave my normal
series of lectures as i normally do
starting with evolution creation and
going on to the other topics and the
biblical topics
and then i had
the wine of babylon and then
two lectures
on
bible bible translations
and
it was like a bomb that exploded
it was
consternation like you cannot believe
now remember all of these students
are at the theological seminary they're
being trained to be pastors
and they come to me and they say no
everything you're saying is absolutely
wrong because look here's our textbooks
and they showed me their textbooks and
there it says that the received text is
the very worst text to base your bible
translation on in other words you must
accept those manuscripts that were found
in waste paper baskets right and that
the vatican used yeah
and ellen and white in the spirit of
prophecy is absolutely clear that rome
would change the bible
and that the valdez's were the ones that
had the true manuscripts
and the manuscripts that erasmus had
they were the ones that corrected the
errors of
the previous ones that were available
like the vulgate
and this was exactly the opposite so
what i was saying
was exactly the opposite of what they
taught
at that university
and so there was huge consternation
and i sat down with those students
afterwards and we took the bible and i
said let's read and i had written in the
back of my bible all the changes and
they were astounded but of course
the fury of that university leadership
was
beyond explanation
and as a consequence of the furore
the they decided
the whole leadership of germany decided
that that was a reason to have me banned
from speaking
so i was banned yeah to speak in germany
in the country in the country yes so
that was my first time that they banned
me
from ever speaking again in
in germany in
in an adventist environment
now what did that create
it created a debate right exactly
and here a debate started
not only in germany
but in the entire world
regarding this issue
and today if you read the spirit of
prophecy then especially those
manuscripts that have been released
recently
and we've dealt with it in a previous
what's up the people can you can put a
link back into that one where it is
absolutely crystal clear that the spirit
of prophecy
says that the true manuscripts
were in the hands of the valdenzus and
erasmus and therefore are the
manuscripts that corrected the errors of
the previous ones
but many of the theologians in the world
not only at that university but at many
of our institutes were teaching the
exact opposite
now this causes a debate modern since
then many books have been written not
only wilkinson i mean there are many
books in the world yeah i have a whole
shelf full of them and i've read them
all
and to me it is absolutely
incomprehensible
especially if you read the studies of
the committee of the
bible for example and the research that
they did before they brought that bible
out
and the result is that many many people
returned to the received text
and this created much consternation i
have two books here
that were written subsequently
to wilkinson these are two that come out
of the pens of adventists this one is by
martin klein
and it's above all thy name it's a very
very interesting book
about
bible translations and a recent one that
just came out
is by miloslav dunker
and
we must find out what his web page is so
that we can refer people to put some
links in it
and it's called the word of god versus
modern bible versions history of the
original and its counterfeits
so
this debate
was opened up within the church
now
i was of course also called into higher
echelons within the church
to
be informed that this was not a very
wise thing to do to open this can of
worms
which historically brought me back to
some of the events of the past and
how this whole thing has been addressed
and i do not recall ever having read a
fundamental belief that i may not
believe the received text which was used
by all the reformers and by the spirit
of prophecy yes why should i not be able
to believe that right
so there is no fundamental belief
on that issue so there should be no
reason to tell me that i cannot accept
one or the other
and nobody has the the right to decide
for me or anyone else
what they should believe on the issue if
you have something to say present your
facts yes that you can get a discussion
and get the discussion going and this is
exactly what happened you can do nothing
against the truth
all right it took a
little bit of a confrontation
to create the debate
but the debate
went worldwide
and today there are people on both sides
of the issue and that's fine
everybody must decide for themselves
where they stand on the issue
and
we're not going to go to war on it
but
as for me and my house i will make one
decision and somebody else might make
the alternative decision
so i've never retracted what i said
even though it was requested that i
retract
in fact
the leadership
in europe
called me in
and told me what i was not allowed to
speak about
so i was not allowed to speak about
all plant-based diet
i'm terribly sorry because the spirit of
prophecy tells me the opposite
then i was told
my view on the papacy is outdated and i
mean there were articles written by
conference presidents and union
presidents
in magazines stating quite plainly that
that is updated 19th century thinking
and that it shouldn't be tolerated
within the church
well that's that president's opinion and
his opinion is contrary to the spirit of
prophecy
and therefore i can ignore him and it's
also contrary to the official church
stand on it correct
then it's it's always strange to me
that when these leaders
write these things and say these things
they're not banned
no they're not banned they continue in
their positions of power but they're not
seventh-day adventists
they are not
of us although they are
in us and this is how you must see it
but the interesting thing martin
is that that president might say that
but the other one will say the exact
opposite so it doesn't make the entire
leadership apostate
it just refers to those individuals and
the same
when it comes to all of these issues
they told me
i may not speak against trade unions
this is a union president who tells me
i'm not allowed to speak about trade
unions
and i said to him but the the spirit of
prophecy says that the trade unions will
be one of the means to bring about a
time of trouble such as never was and
that we should have nothing to do with
them that our very souls are in peril if
we associate with these organizations
you're not allowed to warn people about
that
and he said
not in germany
so i said to him and his group that were
there i said
it's very strange
all right
i'll make a deal with you
i won't say it in germany
on one condition
that you say
that the blood is on your head
if people don't hear this and are
actually lost because of it it's on your
head
do you know what they did
they went and huddled in a corner over
there and had a little brief discussion
on it and then came back and said that's
fine
it sounds like is uh israel when they
crucified jesus
his blood beyond our his blood be on our
head i was absolutely stunned
now i've had many nerve-wracking
experiences like that
and the interesting thing is
that
the controversy
even while i was banned
didn't go away right
it raged within the church
because it opened up a debate
and this is the crux of the matter you
can do nothing against the truth you can
only do something for the truth
it's always like that
and so eventually after a number of
years or whatever it was
they
because of
pressure probably unbanned me
so i was allowed to speak again
until the next exciting episode happened
so
well there were als always those that
were looking for a reason
why i should not speak
secret societies is one of their pet
hates
so the issues are always the same
it's the six thousand
year age of the earth
and the statements in the spirit of
prophecy regarding time
it's the the question of the position of
the papacy
whether the papacy has changed
in fact when
this overseeing body within the church
that has to deal with doctrinal issues
confronted me on the bible translations
and i would send them
correspondence is unbelievable
i would send them
the information that i have
they would write back to me and say
that the realm that we are dealing with
is not the same realm
all right
this is problematic yeah because the
spirit of prophecy clearly says rome
does not change does not change and
anybody who lessens the distance between
themselves and rome is a backsliding
church then they would write back to me
and they would say
the roman catholic church has no
interest in changing christology
and i wrote back to them and i said
excuse me no interest in changing
christology
but they put mediators such as mary and
saints in the place of jesus christ
they say that the atonement
was
not for us it was just an act of
obedience but it didn't atone for our
sins
they are against the doctrine of
justification and they have no no desire
to change the christology
eventually it got to the point where i
said you know
we have absolutely nothing in common in
terms of
this way of thinking so
thank you very much for your opinion but
uh no thank you i'll keep my opinion
so this is how it happened
but within those same bodies
there are people
that are
absolutely
faithful to the bible and the spirit of
prophecy it depends on who you are
dealing with yes it's the church it's
a history
has shown us that it's inside the church
both parties correct now while all this
was going on they were of course
deciding at one stage to print the great
controversy
and to hand that out
now knowing the sentiment of many of
these people
that i'd met
it was obvious to me that this was going
to be a war right
and one of the leaders in europe in
germany
who was part of this economical
gathering or economical council that
they were in
wrote an article and lamented the fact
that we should be in this day and age be
handing out outdated books like
the great controversy
and what had happened was
uh in one of these meetings
the roman catholic delegate
had come to him and said to him
all right you're a you're a seventh day
adventist
but you people hand out the great
controversy
and you're sitting here in this in this
council and do you still believe that my
church the roman catholic church is the
of babylon
and so he lamented the fact in his
article
that we should have such outmoded and
outdated um
negative documentation that we were
still willing to hand out because it's
putting him in a bad light correct and
he he said that he was so flabbergasted
he didn't know what to say
and so he felt you know terribly bad
that we as a denomination should believe
such things
and i still thought to myself you know
what an opportunity
because many years ago i also
was asked
to
represent our church here in south
africa
at a meeting
that had been called not with that we
were members or anything but
it was kind of an economical meeting
to be called about the situation in
south africa and what they what the
churches could do and i was to represent
them
and
they wanted to vote on certain actions
that had to be taken
and
every single hand we went up
to vote on a particular issue
except mine
and they were very upset
you know
all eyes immediately i mean you do feel
very strange right you're sitting there
and all eyes suddenly are new
and uh
they looked at me and they said and and
you why are you not voting
so i said to them well you know i'm not
voting
because i don't have the right to vote
i'm here
to represent
the church but i cannot make decisions
for the church
i haven't been empowered with that
position with that authority
the church has to make this decision so
i have to take it back to them and say
this is what they want they want us to
vote on this issue then we can then we
can make this decision and they were
talking about issues
about how the church must dictate to the
state as to
what must happen
and i said then i said and by the way if
i if i may say something
you are talking about telling the state
what to do
now you are all protestants and
different religions here
and i know that all of you stand for
sunday rest
and i'm a seventh day adventist
so if i vote along with you now and then
it comes to the point where you want to
introduce sunday legislation
then
we would be on opposite sides of of the
table
so how would we deal with that
so that that opened a discussion over
there amongst all those people
it was an opportunity yes right you can
do nothing against the truth you can
only do something for the truth it was
very uncomfortable
and i was sweating profusely
but it was an opportunity
and you know what they said
they said if you become a member of our
organization
then we could protect you
if you're not sorry if you're not sorry
and i thought okay thank you very much
that is exactly what i would expect so i
thought about this man
who wrote this article and i thought you
know what an opportunity
he could have said to the man
my dear friend
i have nothing against you personally
and i have nothing against roman
catholics
many many are
faithful people that want to do what is
right
but here is my question
do you still teach that there are
mediators other than jesus christ can
you approach mary
in a mediatorial position or any of the
saints if your answer is yes
well
then we can move to the next point do
you still teach
that the mass is a literal sacrifice the
same identical sacrifice that happened
on the cross
do you still teach that in the light of
the bible saying that by one sacrifice
he has forever made perfect
do you teach that jesus christ didn't
die for us
but died
as an example of obedience
and that you still have to attain
through your good works
do you still believe that and you go
through the doctrines and then you say
as a consequence of that you are not in
harmony with the bible
and the bible calls that spiritual
adultery
so in terms of your doctrine i'm afraid
we are not on the same page but as a
person
that's a totally different thing that
would have been a witness he had an
opportunity no he laments that we're
handing out the great controversy
and so they finally did reduce the great
controversy to the size of a postage
stamp
and handed that out having taken out
every reference to the papacy as the
beast
or any one of those issues
claiming that you should actually
come out of babylon
but failing to define who babylon is
it's a totally useless document
and
this is the the result of this kind of
thinking
if you have a truth martin
you have to stand for it
absolutely and if you stand for it
god opens the doors yes
and that
which he wants to become an issue of
debate
even through the circumstances which are
uncomfortable
to both parties
and in
in terms of conflict
and painful to the to the extreme
if the debate opens up and people make
decisions then god has achieved his
purpose
whether the one side is right or the
other side is right is then an issue of
debate within the church as a body
and this is what the shaking is all
about this quote comes from the spirit
of prophecy volume 4 page 423
in every generation
god has sent his servants to rebuke sin
both in the world and in the church
but the people desire smooth things to
be spoken to them
and the pure unvarnished truth is not
acceptable
many reformers in entering upon their
work determined to exercise great
prudence
in attacking the sins of the church and
the nation they hoped by the example of
a pure christian life
to lead the people back to the doctrines
of the bible
but the spirit of god came upon them as
it came upon elijah and they could not
refrain from preaching the plain
utterances of the bible
doctrines which they had been reluctant
to present they were impelled to
zealously declare the truth and the
danger which threatened souls
the words which the lord gave them they
uttered
fearless of consequences and the people
were compelled to hear
the warning
button this has been
the way in which god has dealt
throughout the ages
and if somebody gets up and preaches
something
then god is opening up
an avenue of discussion
if that something is blatantly wrong
it will be revealed that it is blatantly
wrong yes
if it is not blatantly wrong but
contains truth
then that truth will not fall to the
ground that seed will not return empty
yes
so
this is the way in which people within
this church must decide what is right
and what is wrong
i cannot listen to something because so
and so said it
whether that person is a leader in the
church or whether that person is a
layperson in the church irrespective
i have to judge it on the bible and the
spirit of prophecy the same applies to
anything that i or any other evangelist
has to say
we are not the talmud of this church
we are not a creed for this church
we are just people
speaking
what we have discovered
in the bible and the spirit of prophecy
and if it holds water
and if it is in harmony with the bible
and the spirit of prophecy
then buy it yes and if it is not
then reject it correct that's what we do
correct
so it's not my job to go and ban those
people in leadership
and tell them
that
they are banned from speaking my
personal opinion is
that if they say these things
then they are not
in harmony with the spirit of adventism
but that doesn't make my church babylon
no
don't boycott the church because of the
leaders or any apostasy
correct we want the church back to what
it's supposed to be i want my church
back
cd brooks preached that
and i conquer i want my church back i
don't
want this modern stuff i don't want the
spiritual formation because it destroys
your mind it takes your
mind away from the truth and puts you on
a road of liturgy and activity
and keeps you
jumping up and down physical exercise
profiteth little
i want my church back i want my church
to believe in the bible and the spirit
of prophecy
i was in a in a place i'll tell that in
another story
i was in a place
where i didn't want to go
but i ended up there anyway
you definitely have to tell that one
i'll tell that next time
and there was a lady and she had a theme
song every night
and uh the theme song went something
like god said it
and i believe it
and that's the way it is that settles it
that settles it for me that's it and it
sort of stuck in my mind
and it's become an axiom
my my favorite verse
in all the bible
is
trust in the lord with all thine heart
and lean not on thine own understanding
in all thy ways acknowledge him
and he
shall
direct
thy path amen let's close with prayer
heavenly father
sometimes this road is so rocky
and so painful
but lord it is a road that leads to
eternity
help us not to reject truth
because it is painful
help us not to reject truth because the
road is rocking
help us to embrace truth that you make
prominent
through the rocky road
bless us
as we continue our discussions
and may you bless your church
and may you bring many many many to lead
others
to the path of life in jesus name i pray
amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again